what what does this story look like you
know I can tell you what it looks like
here it's a battle about Tesla but I
would imagine over there it's it's got a
very different viewpoint well in terms
of who Apple's car might compete with
Tessa would be a prime target because
they're the big electric car company
right now now but remember Mitsubishi
she's got an electric car General Motors
has one and they're bringing a new one
out BMW as well I sort of see this as
Apple is would be targeting anybody who
already has Apple products remember
these guys have hardcore fans at Apple
anyone with an iPhone anyone with a Mac
anyone with an iPad Apple people just
love their products and if that Apple
person happens to be driving a Rolls
Royce or a Mustang or a I don't know
some cheap compact car they're gonna
look at Apple's car whenever this thing
comes out assuming they get the project
done of course do the car makers in
Detroit look at Apple's as a serious
competitor or as this scene with some
bemusement
mm probably bleed more of amusement you
know these guys sort of scoffed at Tesla
for many years saying that they would
never get it done and in fairness to the
people in Detroit who sort of think that
way you know in one hand
Tesla's made it but a handful of
electric cars startups over the past
five to seven years have all failed so
there there aren't there's a whole
Boothill of companies that try to get
into this and couldn't get it done on
the other hand Tesla did make it so you
can't really dismiss a company with a
hundred and seventy eight billion in
cash like Apple does so they're sort of
watching this yeah there's the amusement
but they're also kind of wondering okay
do they get this done and then if they
do okay maybe we should really start
worrying at that point we have this
author on the show yesterday Steve
Levine talking about the the battle to
create a better battery in the
automakers desire to make a better
battery and there's a fascinating book
with a surprisingly a lot of drama
around it but I think that one of the
takeaways is that companies like GM and
Ford and others have in Detroit are real
technology companies that have spent a
lot of time and money trying to invent
better ways to make a battery for
example can Apple really compete with
the kind of hour and
that those guys have already got gotten
into in the material science they've dug
dug into for many years it probably can
because they have the money to do it and
because they've gone to a whole bunch of
battery suppliers looking for the best
chemistry's they're already using
lithium-ion in their consumer
electronics devices so they certainly
got that expertise it's not their core
competency to develop the better battery
although they've certainly got our and D
there but they're very familiar with the
space and the automaker's also rely
heavily on their suppliers for advanced
is there and they do their own work so
the automaker's having basically a
cooperative kind of R&D with the battery
makers Apple already has that as well
it's it's a different kind of battery
but they could certainly do it I don't
think it would take long to catch up
there especially given the amount of
money Apple has and the amount of clout
they have with with the companies out
there doing battery work and final this
time for him I find it kind of shocking
that they think they have a car in
production in five years is that you
know when Detroit launches a new car
five to seven years why does it take
Detroit five to seven years to do that
I'm actually a little surprised to see
that figure to be honest with you
the Detroit companies can get a new car
out in three two four sometimes it is
five but five to seven would be for
somebody maybe like Apple who is
starting from scratch they don't have a
whole family of chess he's a big
supplier Network and so forth
you know the Detroit car companies can
actually get cars out and sometimes two
years if they've already got a lot of
the existing hardware with another model
and they're just gonna create a new
model off of that that existing
underpinning said so I you know five to
seven is a very very long time now look
five years for a company like Apple who
is simply studying this right at this
point they have done work but they're
not they don't have factories and this
sort of thing that's pretty aggressive
yeah